[Music]
[Applause]
okay we're back on the Internet
John asked do you believe it's right to
withhold Miranda rights from any
American I guess that's being asked
because I think I saw right before I
came on the air that they were holding
with Miranda rights from the incessant
unibrow bomber yeah correct they're
calling him a high-value detainee
and what does that mean and why are we
doing that and white why don't we rely
on why don't we have faith in our
justice system well in the past for a
high-value detainee you don't read them
as Miranda rights because you want to
get information from him and you don't
want the lawyer called into the room
immediately and you know these are for
you know enemy non-combatants who it
could be argued don't necessarily
deserve Miranda rights at this point in
the process you're trying to squeeze
information out of them you're trying to
find out what other plots might be
ongoing and as we know at this case
there are three other people detained so
perhaps it is a larger plot we really
just don't know yet can I just interject
there's actually a Supreme Court case
from the 1980s which says if there's a
there's a public safety exception until
with a guy who secreted a gun in a
supermarket so the Supreme Court is
actually ruled on this we don't have to
go to enemy combatants and all that kind
of Bush quasi law does actually Supreme
Court decision on this and it says if
there's an imminent threat so where's
the gun that kinda thing the other thing
is with Abdulmutallab the underwear
bomber who I'm December 25th
2009 was arrested there was actually two
teams of FBI agents one who questioned
him from a national security perspective
and that evidence was only used to
protect the nation another team
protected another team asking questions
for prosecution right but I do I does
make me feel profoundly uncomfortable
when we make exceptions on things like
Miranda and I think that this time is we
we pursue a tactical advantage it okay
we want to get any tactical advantage we
can right here but there's a real
strategic cost to doing that and I think
that's so often the way we pursue things
we pursue this tactical advantage and LU
strategically your secure recipe used in
court against the you know detainee I
just think just reading the damn rights
trust our system trust the system
I think so because otherwise what you're
saying is really we want to have him in
a room with no lights and beat him up
but that's really what you're saying is
you're trying to you know find out if
this is a ticking time bomb scenario or
not and you said if there is imminent
threat that that person does not have to
be read their Miranda rights to try to
tackle it it's like enhanced
interrogation techniques it's like a
euphemism for torture which torture is
quite different than not having your
rights read there's there's a difference
I mean I'm not supporting one way or the
other what I am saying is this this is
not extrajudicial there's a Supreme
Court precedent for this and I think
that tortures is a different thing you
your rights are there I think there's a
legitimate issue as to and I happen to
believe as a former police officer that
you shouldn't read people that rise
however there's a different reading not
being read your rights and having them
and being tortured you think you message
out to the world I mean to Putin to
China when we when we make these kinds
of exceptions I I remember Chinese
officials telling me when I was
complaining about their abusive or
taking shortcuts with it oh if we if you
faced our problems then you would do the
same thing and I was you know saying oh
we would never do that and then 9/11
happened I felt I needed ray didn't need
to make exceptions to defeat the Nazis
or the Soviet Union but that's not true
the Kiran case in the 1940s Korematsu we
locked up japanese-americans we took
enemy combat stress we took enemy
combatants with without a civilian trial
tried six of them out of aid and we
executed them that was Roosevelt a
Democrat and that was a source of not of
national strength but of regional
weakness I think I don't think it's fair
to say that questioning a suspect is the
equivalent of torturing them we
questioned them in the court that you
know and we try to build a case against
them they get much anymore they
questioned by police
that's not torture that's investigation
no but to question them without them or
underwrites does that mean they're
getting cups of tea and being treated
through the civil way or not I think
what would you walk with you bet what
would you both be Thanks
lots of water and you can get the DNA
well but we did see in the paper this
week there was a think tank that
issued a report on Bush's torture and it
was rather more pervasive than we
thought even and we thought it was
pretty bad and it was coming from on
high and hooting Republicans including
Republicans ASA Hutchinson was on the
committee so it was not lacking
bipartisanship and I just think that
that is a black mark on our record and
it always will be and obviously all the
arguments have been made that when our
guys get captured there's nothing to
prevent other people from torturing them
and saying America does it too yeah it
makes our order to make a case you know
in speaking at some of them and I work
with the writers organization pen and
the thing is if you go and talk about
what's being done to people in other
countries and try and persuade that to
stop but they'll say well what are you
doing what about what's happening in
Guantanamo Bay what's happening you you
know how can you make a claim about what
we should do when you when you're doing
the same thing it weakens it weakens the
caralyn somebody asked do you think
social media contributes to isolation
lack of empathy and makes people less
sensitive to the suffering of others
good question it is there's a you know
since it coolness in the sense that I
can want to go play a game with somebody
from France and Argentina and Japan all
at the same time but at the same time
how I'm doing that is yes staring at a
screen I'm not actually looking at
someone's face instead of going outside
and knocking on some doors engaging with
another human writing I'm sitting in a
room by myself staring at a screen I
mean if you ever try to communicate with
someone via email or text and you lose
so much of that context you lose so much
of what you're trying to say that I
think it does it's hard to it's hard for
someone in my generation to relate to
that when they meant I Te'o case
surfaced like it was very I mean I I
couldn't understand it how you can have
a girlfriend that you've never met maybe
I know what it's like to have it not to
have a girlfriend
I remember I remember those days but I
didn't I didn't think the long pass and
I didn't think I had one I had my hand I
knew but I you know I mean I wasn't
fooling myself that my hand was named
Lily you know I mean but I wasn't it was
named Lily but I mean I wasn't fooling
myself but I would like to point out
that this question is being asked by
someone who is watching us online as we
speak yes that's right we're all right
now
that's gonna create you follow us on
Twitter everything okay Amy white and
heimer then let's keep it there next
question to you as an economics graduate
what system would you prefer the
government implement to make
corporations pay for externalities such
as carbon emissions uh what would I
advocate for that well I don't
necessarily advocate corporations paying
for externalities like carbon emissions
really really but I don't we've been
down this road before build it as much
global warming's a hoax I remember I
forgot local warming is a hoax according
to today's Republicans foisted on us by
moveon.org you know radical radical
liberal organizations have made up
global warming in order to oppress us I
feel like all right I thought it was Al
Gore I thought he was in cádiz in this
only way with climate scientist yeah
gonna make money off this yes yes okay
um you're free to go
thank you very much for indulging us
tonight and okay
a Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
of Jan asked bill and his guests or
questions right after the show at HBO
calm